hello my name is hannah pesci
i am a scientist at thermo fisher
scientific and i will be giving a
product development update today
on thermo fissure scientific's new
amplitude solution for code
19 testing
when the coronavirus outbreak began in
late 2019
thermo fisher science fick rapidly
developed one of the first
cobin 19 diagnostic tests which is now
scaled to manufacture
20 million tests per week thermo fisher
scientific is working to apply its skill
as the world leader in serving science
to standardize and
industrialize the manufacture of tests
and testing platforms
in a reliable and reproducible way to
support the global need for testing at
scale
we have the ability to manufacture up to
20 million tests
which we are currently approaching now
what does this mean
globally over half of all copen 19
testing is currently being performed on
thermal fissure scientific instruments
we have rapidly increased our production
of kova 19 kits and continue to increase
our manufacturing
to 20 million reactions per week and
beyond if needed
laboratories have been constrained with
supplies from reagents to consumables
and instruments
the thermofisher will provide an assured
supply for your laboratory to ensure
there are no concerns in your workflow
and throughput
for cobin 19 testing thermo fisher
scientific is
vertically integrated we are the single
supplier and distributor for consumables
reagents
instruments software and 24 7 service
and support for laboratories running or
looking to run
coding testing
what we are introducing today is the
amplitude solution
while patient testing demand continues
to increase as testing becomes more
readily available
there are still most current options are
i'm going to restart that one
what we are introducing today is the
amplitude solution
patient testing demand continues to
increase as testing becomes more readily
available
but most current options are unable to
process and supply reagents to the
volumes
that are needed to keep up with this
demand current non-autonomous options
result in an increase in the number of
full-time employees
staffing overhead and human related
errors that occur with more routine
manual processes
and large number of instruments from
multiple vendors are required to support
these workflow
third-party automation options are
available however they include long lead
times to scale
and require large footprints within the
clinical laboratories
the upcoming thermo fisher scientific
amplitude covid19 testing solution is an
automated molecular diagnostic testing
system
that can analyze over 7000 specimens in
a single day
with the reliability and confidence of
secured assay and
reagent supply along with 24 7
world-class service and support
offering sample to result cova 19
testing the amplitude
solution requires minimal hands-on time
equipment and staffing needs
utilizing the applied biosystems tacpath
covenant team
real-time pcr assay which has
consistently delivered superior
sensitivity and specificity to the
detection of the stars co2 virus
the amplitude solution can help
laboratories quickly scale cova-19
testing to the volumes needed
to reduce the spread of diseases and
help restore economies and communities
the amplitude solution delivers a number
of key benefits to the clinical
laboratory
the amplitude solution provides a
secured supply source for consumables
and reagents with the supply agreement
it provides reduced staffing needs by
using only four
full-time employees through a high
throughput
footprint with the ability to analyze
over 7000 coven 19 samples in just 24
hours
the automation allows for minimal
hands-on time for increased efficiency
in sample processing
while requiring minimal equipment when
compared to manual alternatives
it utilizes a proven sensitive and
specific coven 19
testing assay and provides 24 7 support
for helping guide you through any
situation during these novel times
and ultimately it provides a single
source for providing everything you need
including all equipment
consumables reagents and 24 7 support
at a high level the amplitude solution
consists of two modules
the first module or module one is the
tcam fluent 1080 liquid handler
and the second module which consists of
extraction through pcr setup and data
analysis
is composed of a number of smaller
pieces of equipment which we will go
through shortly
the workflow consists of the following
steps
sample accessioning which requires
receiving
the sample tubes from the clinical site
which is then transferred into module 1.
module 1 consists of the building of 4
96 deep well plates
which are then transferred into module 2
for extraction and pcr setup
the output of module 2 is then a series
of results
which are then provided back to the
customer for reporting purposes
we'll now go through each of these steps
in a little bit more detail
sample accessioning consists of
receiving tubes
i'm just going to restart
sample accessioning begins with the
patient tube
so the clinical sample is received by
the lab and this
tube needs to be barcoded and decapped
prior to be put on
sample carrier racks which are provided
to the customer
these sample carrier racks will then be
transferred into module 1.
the samples received into labs are
required to be in the form of viral
transport media or vtm
and will integrate into the customer's
own limb systems
so once these samples are received they
can be barcoded if they are not already
barcoded and decapped prior to putting
on the sample carriers which are then
transferred
into module 1.
once these samples are received and
transferred onto module 1 and the
provided sample carriers
the tcam fluent 1080 is going to
transfer each of these samples
into a deep well plate the depot plate
will then also be filled with reagents
required for extraction
this includes binding buffer beads
protein sk
and ms2 are extraction control to help
track
performance throughout the entire
process we similarly add negative
control wells to ensure
the extraction performs as expected
the built for 96 depot plates will then
be transferred into module two
due to the addition of binding buffer
and beads during this step
the samples are further considered and
activated due to the addition of the
binding buffer
the generated 4 96 depot plates from
module 1 are then loaded into module 2.
you'll see here the module 2 has a few
more subsystems involved
once those depot plates are placed onto
module 2 they then go
to the kingfisher prestos each 96 depot
plate
is extracted on a different kingfisher
presto
once extraction is completed and the
nucleic acid has been extracted and
isolated
into a final deep well plate that
aleutian depot plate is then transferred
into the tcam fluence 780
a liquid handler the four
depot plates are then generated and
built into one
384 well pcr plate on the t-cam fluid
once the 384 well plate is built it then
is subsequently moved to a plate sealer
for ceiling and centrifuge for
centrifugation prior to being placed
on one of two quant studio 7 flexes on
deck
rt pcr then occurs within the quant
studio flex
and the results are generated
once the results are completed the
sample result data is sent to applied
biosystems coven 19
interpretive software for final
reporting
this gives a high level overview of what
the amplitude solution looks like from
sample
acquisition through module one and
finally through result generation in
module two
now what i've had the opportunity to
work on and contribute in this platform
is really in the r d
testing so i'll provide a brief overview
of what the development
that has gone on from the r d side has
looked like throughout the different
phases of this project
now what it comes down to is the series
of different testing phases from
conception of the instrument through
final clinical evaluation
and what you see here is really we just
went through many different layers of
testing looking at different test
protocols and approaches to evaluating
our instrument
from basic subsystem testing through the
full integration and clinical evaluation
and really what's highlighted here is
just the sheer number of plates and
number of samples
that were processed in the development
of the system
and also the opportunity of this system
due to its high throughput nature
to generate this many results
now one of the subsystems that we
evaluate are subverse
so in generating a lot of this data we
broke our testing plan into what we
called sip phases or system integration
plan and i will walk through one of
these system integration plans next
so while the previous slide showed at a
high level the different types of phases
we looked at
one of those phases we called sip two or
system integration plan
two and this plan really looked at
generating data
at different risk factors and
characterizing the amplitude solution
as it was being developed in kind of
earlier feasibility
the system integration plan was not the
execution of just one protocol but many
many runs across
a series of different tests not only at
one site but at two of our
sites at thermo fisher scientific
to give you a high level overview of
what was done we looked at a series of
different protocols or objectives within
this testing plan
including cross contamination to ensure
that as we transition
from our established manual ea workflow
to a more automated solution we were not
introducing any risk
during our liquid handling that might
result in cross-contamination so we
extensively looked in this
to make sure the risk was well
characterized
and cross-contamination was not present
similarly we then looked at
a quantitative metric of performance
again evaluating against our established
eua protocol
looking at ranges of concentrations from
very low
to very high at 25 xlod
we then branched out to focus more at
the lod level and really get a good
picture
of how our system was performing on
multiple runs across multiple sites
and then we transitioned to not only
looking at different concentrations
to characterizing risk but also looking
at matrix variability
and ensure that we were encompassing
any matrix variability that might be
encountered in the field
during our testing phases with protocol
4
where we looked at hundreds of
individual np samples
all collected from different patients at
different sites
and what i'll go into next is a closer
look at what protocol 2
actually looked like from an r d phase
now protocol 2 was designed to give us a
better picture of what was going on
across a wider range of concentrations
of spiked in copen19 inactivated virus
you can see in the lower left the
hundreds of
sample tubes that were filled and
prepared in order to be placed on module
one which again was a fluent 1080t can
these samples were then transferred into
those four 96 depot plates on module one
and then built into the resultant pcr
plate you can see in the upper right
on module two and you can see the
concentrations were designed such that
they span the entire
length of the plate to provide a closer
look at what was going on
and each step of the way
so what the results from protocol 2
established was that across multiple
sites we were able to meet the eua
performance
and hit 1xlod with high confidence
similarly
it established that we were able to
perform at a similar level across each
of these different concentrations as
well as at the 0x lod level
and what most importantly this
highlighted was just the number of
samples
and the throughput of the system that we
were developing
so in addition to maintaining
performance against the manual eua
amplitude truly gives us the opportunity
to continue to support carbon 19 testing
demands globally
but now in a high throughput system
and now i would like to thank you for
your time and follow up with
any questions